how's it going guys welcome back to
another episode of design patterns today
we're going to be looking at the bridge
design pattern I'm going to talk about
it briefly here before we get started
but I'd like to just jump in and show
you the example because I think it'll
make a lot more sense as this one
although it's sort of simple once you do
it it's a little hard to kind of
understand uh based on the language
usually used to describe it which is
something like this decouple and
abstraction from its implementation
so that the two can vary independently
all right we'll we'll unpack that don't
worry and uh let's see what else do they
say about it publish an interface in an
inheritance hierarchy and bury the
implementation in its own inheritance
hierarchy I'm finding this on a
sourcemaking.com design patterns not
sponsored that's just where I'm pulling
this particular lingo
and so what we're going to do here
basically is consider a case where the
normal inheritance structure doesn't
work quite right anymore so let me give
you an example and we're going to do
this with a set of classes like an RPG
so some of you might like that all right
so I've already done all the cmake stuff
as we do at the beginning of every
episode just added it to those I added a
new project called it Bridge PC and
we're going to start adding some files I
have a main here that's completely empty
let's go ahead and just make an in Main
and we're going to talk about it as we
go but first I'd like to give you the
first part of this example consider the
case of we add we want to add a player
all right we want to have whatever RPG
game system we're making here uh we're
kind of starting from the Bare Bones and
we want to have a player so we want them
to be able to do some special things
like we want them to be able to select
their class or their specialty rather
how they're going to level up their
level path if you will and we also want
them to be able to choose what race of
the available races and we'll just start
with that that's going to be enough for
this example so we want a player we want
them to be able to pick their class in
race and this might sort of come to you
naturally and if it does great but the
problem that people run into and you
know maybe this is a bit of a contrived
simpler example but it could really be
for anything if you're having this
happen so we're going to make a
player.h's little player cash here and
put our pragma once up at the top let's
go class player
all right so if a player can have a a
race we think okay so maybe we want to
clash for that too a race class
and I'm not going to fill these out yet
I'm just kind of making the example
first and we also want a uh well I can't
call the class class because uh that
doesn't work too well I guess it does if
you do it with capital c yeah that's
fine okay so you want to raise in a
class and you might think you could just
do something like this just have a
public race and a public class and we're
ready to go the players got both but
this has a problem because at run time
we won't be able to change the race we
won't be able to change the class so
that's the big issue here uh if we did
we'd have to do something like enum uh
class type or something
and put all our class types in an enum
or something like that we'd have to like
do it in this sort of fashion and it
would get very very messy and big you
could do it but
the bridge is made to solve this problem
because you essentially have to do this
with the rates too and eventually you
just got all these types and well this
isn't the worst but what happens here
eventually I'll just make a few uh like
unpicked or elf what else we're going to
put in here working out is fine
um let's add gnome or felt gnome and we
could do the same thing here for classes
what classes did we want well let's just
do fighter wizard robe
or I'm going to call it Warrior Warrior
wizard Rogue all right so you could you
could design these in a way where you
could modify them but where the real
problem comes in is when you want to add
another one say you want to make a
little expansion pack later or decide to
update your code and you just after
you've done a whole bunch of stuff uh
throughout these classes modifying this
um like maybe you've got special switch
cases that allow you to pick these and
same for these and then at some point
you decide okay uh we're suddenly going
to add the Monk class and then you've
got to update all your switch statements
every all your choose logic there's
going to be a whole Cascade of things
you have to update just to add one class
later if you didn't have it all
premeditated and ready to go which let's
face it there's always going to be an
expansion to anything that need you know
it's just the way it goes so there's a
better way of making this more
maintainable because yeah while you
could do it this way this way gets just
real ugly real fast is from a main pain
ability standpoint so I hope I'm making
that clear because yes you can do it
with whatever way you manage to come up
with but if you want to do it in a way
that's easy to expand later and I'll
prove it to you as we go that it's easy
to expand later let me give you a show
of that all right so instead of having
all this just get rid of these get rid
of this
and we'll do it a different way and get
rid of this player doesn't need to
inherit from these but rather instead of
inheriting
we'll just make them composed in the
clouds so we'll have a race
pointer and we'll just underscore
release there's that and same with this
so it's just going to be better to have
them composed in this case and I'm going
to show you how to build this all up so
we do need an interface for the race and
the class all right let's make our own
files for these
like race and I guess I could call it
class using the keyword class is a bit
touchy so we got to be careful with that
but we'll we'll manage
okay
so we'll just delete these for now we'll
leave player alone we'll come back to
player of course we're going to we know
we're going to need to include race in
class so let's go ahead and get that in
there and I'm going to go kind of deep
here I'm going to do quite a bit of
coding and get into this because for
once I have prepared before so I
shouldn't fumble too much buckle up if
you'd like to support me please consider
joining the channel or the patron or if
you can find me on GitHub you can
support me on there as well it means a
lot for continuing these episodes I'm
going to try to my darn just to release
a video every Wednesday this year the
only foreseeable reason I think that I
might give up mid-year is if things keep
down trending because uh you know after
the holidays a lot of things kind of
Tanked a bit
and it's a it's a bit rough and I'm I am
developing a game on my own so a lot of
my time goes into that so it does take a
good bit of my energy to switch gears
and do these videos so I just kind of
want to make sure I'm actually focused
where I should be focused so your
support means it's on seeing seeing that
stuff makes a big difference so
consider liking sharing whatever you
want to do even if you're just leaving
me good feedback that's often good too
or leaving a comment and all that stuff
so we're looking for a nice positive 20
23 and uh
yeah I guess uh we'll go from there look
forward to 52 videos and if there's any
updates I'll post them in future videos
so that's all I wanted to say about that
stuff appreciate you guys that do
support me and future people that do it
means a lot all right so
we got a player we got a race in a class
composed in here now how do we make
these races and classes properly and
let's show that these are the ones that
are going to have the inheritance
structure because well this one Let's uh
let's do the class first we want to
multiply one and we want the default
class this is the interface so naturally
we're going to do what we require here
you want to have virtual Destructor
let's make a default that is required
for these pure virtual classes and we
need a virtual function of some sort
here all right now that I'm out of that
toasty robe I should be able to focus a
little bit better here so we're just
going to make a I guess we'll make a git
class and we get class name here and
that one is just going to equal zero
because we want to override that and
also make another one for let's see here
well
thinking ahead a little bit classes are
going to need a resource so we'll get
we'll get resource
our resource name rather kind of gonna
take some inspiration from several
different games here as far as how this
is designed a little bit of World of
Warcraft with the resource because I'm
thinking the Wizard's gonna have a Mana
bar the Warriors going to have a rage
bar and the Rogue is going to have an
energy bar so since they're all going to
basically have a bar we only really need
the name later we will handle the stats
all right let's see is there anything
else we need well at some point we're
gonna need to figure out stats but we'll
do that a little later so this is an
interface here very good and we want to
just put in whatever classes we want to
support we've got a warrior and to start
we could just Implement these functions
here
oh let's make sure they actually return
something these are just going to return
strings that's fine for now
so we include string okay and we'll
actually go ahead and do what they do
override return this class name is just
going to be Warrior simple enough there
and the resource name we're going to
return that as rage and this is going to
be youth later as you'll find out
so we also want to think about how else
this lawyer wants to operate so we're
going to have a Constructor that does
maybe something special for warriors for
like the warrior defaults all right and
we're going to do the same for any other
classes we want we'll start out with the
core 3. all right Warrior
wizard named system Mana cool there's a
wizard and we can go on and we'll do a
rogue here Rogue uses
energy all right there we go we've got a
nice Dynamic class we've got an
interface that the player already has so
we could sit we could already set this
to any of those three and we could
change it at runtime if we wanted so
that's awesome we the the problem with
doing it with pure inheritance is it's
stuck at compile time and well if that
doesn't work for you and you're trying
to think of a solution it's probably
this bridge and we're basically going to
do the same thing with race
we'll just make a get race name as the
virtual
and that's good enough for now
and we just want to put all our races in
here we had War we were considering
oh we do need to make sure we inherit
from this stuff
uh did I do that with the class no I
totally forgot to do that so we'll just
get all that in there
inheritance is pretty important there
and then same with the race we want a
Constructor here
and we want the overridden function and
we're just going to make a couple of
these we're going to make one for elf
and we'll make another one
or gnome
all right and this is enough of an
example to at least pick a race in a
class dynamically and even change them
if you want
I had a bit more worked up that is not
entirely relevant to the example but
just kind of shows you how to expand it
because right now basically what you
could do is you could go player
instructor here have it take a race
and have it take a class we can't use
the keyword class here or lowercase so
that's kind of tricky we'll just make it
a c and
whenever you instantiate a player you
just set it to that
and then we can go over to our main
include player here
that includes everything else we need
already and we can Implement a player
say player one and it wants a race in a
class
so we could as you can see here it's
going to accept this default Constructor
unless we delete it so it depends on the
intention of your program in our case we
are going to delete this one or you
could make it private or something now
this actually does require that we do
more stuff check out my rule of three
and rule of five video if you're not
sure but I'm going to kind of skip over
that for now but we at least want to
stop them from default constructing this
but if you want you can get fancy and
apply that stuff if you're actually
going to use this code or parts of this
code
so at this point we could go back over
to our main and go ahead and implement
it now you might notice here that we're
going to need a class and a race
implemented somewhere these are just
pointers we could have this class be the
owner of these pointers but then if we
do that we need to make sure it deletes
them however since it's Dynamic and at
runtime most likely what we want to do
is just have some defaults of these
sitting around because if you think
about it there might be a bunch of
players or you might make a version of
this for NPCs and they might also want
the race in the class and you don't have
to put a bunch of the races in there and
a bunch of classes like you don't you
don't want to put 15 dwarves in memory
because you only need the stats and the
stuff from the doors once does that make
sense hopefully that's kind of another
Point here because if you go like this
and every single one of them then every
time you make a player or if this were
an NPC or you know just some monster or
something every time you make one of
those you're also going to be making
these which just takes up more memory
completely unnecessary that's sort of a
side point of the bridge but it's
something that's kind of important to
realize because basically somewhere in
your your program if you're running this
there's going to be you know you want to
pre-load stuff you see that at the
beginning of every big program is it has
some kind of loading bar and the reason
is it's just preparing resources so
we'll have a dwarf and we'll just call
this default I guess uh we'll just call
it lowercase to work that's fine I
thought about calling it default dwarf
and you just want to give them the
default substantiation and we'll do the
same with all for all these I guess I'll
just type it out
well gnome okay we're going to default
everything all these need to be pointers
of course these don't necessarily have
to be pointers but if they're not
pointers you want to make sure that you
use the reference symbol like we showed
in the last video all right so say
player one gets their selection and they
get to choose a race and maybe they
choose dwarf and they get to choose a
class so let's go ahead and prepare
these classes as well
so now that we have these
all on the Heap ready to go
we can just let the people choose them
and we don't have to do any additional
loading we're just going to use it maybe
it's a dwarf we'll go with the classic
dwarf Warrior all right there's player
one being four foyer so what we're going
to see is if we do some some standard C
out stuff is that it's a dwarf and a
warrior because it's of course going to
pull from
these if we call get race name and uh
your class name and we can also get the
resources so
if you've got the gist of it from here
great but consider how this would work
with other things basically anytime
you've got something that could change
at runtime
um or you want to set it as the program
runs this is a great place for this you
could do this with your graphic API for
example if you want to allow your user
to change between
Vulcan opengl DirectX you could just
have a you could have it composed in
your main thing that's tying everything
together and that way they could just
pick one and it's going to boot up all
the resources for that
um yeah that's that's a great case you
can really do it for anything there's
some classic examples like a light
switch
um you know they all do the same thing
they do a toggle on and off some of them
have a dimmer but
it doesn't have to be a flipper switch
it could be a pull string you know you
could Implement a different one so
there's a lot of other examples out
there is the point and I don't want you
to walk away from this thinking this is
the only way to do it or something but
it is generally
as we go okay I'm gonna move on because
this is part two of the video and this
is where I just fancy this up a little
bit and do some some printing of the
classes and we're going to do some cool
stuff so I hope you stick around but
I've kind of expected most people to
probably not stick around much longer
once they got the gist of it but we're
gonna do the cool part now so all right
basically we're gonna add stats to this
and we're gonna make it a bit Dynamic so
that it actually works a bit like an RPG
and we're going to do it rather quickly
just based on this smart design so the
first thing we want to do is add stats
let's go ahead and just add a stats file
but it's important to realize that this
stats is kind of a side thing it's not
directly related to the bridge pattern
but we want it because our program wants
it we're going to make a class called
stats and actually I think I'm just
going to copy in from what I had earlier
yeah here we go I'm just going to copy
all this in and I'll explain okay so we
have a header here no stats and here's
the stats we have power agility and
mental those are the three main stats
we're going to pull from just keeping a
simple and we also have a Max HP and a
Max resource that's all we need and
since uh we're going to use the type
depth of this because well it's going to
simplify things this is an old C style
thing but basically it allows us to did
not run into the multiple instantiation
problem
at times so
make the struct do the type that struct
and then the name of it twice I know it
seems odd don't worry about it just
that's how you got to do it sometimes
all right we also want to make an
operator to easily add two stats
together so we're just going to overload
or uh not overload we're just going to
make this operator for plus equals on
stats takes a left hand side and a right
hand side that's const Returns the left
hand side after adding to it because
that's what plus equals does and there
it all is
and uh we're just going to make an init
stats um obviously they start at zero
but that's kind of for some initial
calculations
um when we're running later we're going
to use this init stats and all those is
set Power agent agility and Menthol to
One Max HP and Max resource to 100 so
uh that's it for the stats so now we're
going to make use of those and put them
in the class here a little bit so every
class comes with some Associated stats
uh we need to make sure we include this
and yeah there's going to be some other
C plus plus stuff that comes up so you
might learn a few things
so we're just going to have stats here
Publix fine make sure we initialize it
with those brackets and we can say now
when you implement a warrior
we're going to plus up some stats like
maybe the warrior starts out with one
bonus to the stats so we're going to go
stat stop power or yeah plus equals one
and stats dot let's go Max HP plus
equals two
get a little bonus power and HP just for
being a warrior and we'll do similar
things for the wizard and rope we'll
just give them various different stats
here so another great thing about this
is this stuff changes very easily at
runtime so we'll all talk about that a
little more here shortly but we're gonna
give the wizard some plus up to the
mental and maybe some plus after the
resource and we'll give the Rogue
something to agility naturally
let's go on with ones and anything else
we should give this guy maybe we'll give
them
now let's just give him two agility
okay
so there we go now we have some specific
stat differentiation here and we're
going to do a similar thing with race
race is also going to come with some
stats make sure we include stats and we
can say okay what it works get give them
a bit more power you need to get one
bonus power and stats and uh dwarves are
pretty resilient so let's give them some
more HP as well now it seems pretty
obvious right now that they make really
great warriors with all this extra power
in HP
um we'll just give them like to let's
not go overboard
and we'll do something for the elves too
give them some agility and I guess
that's it let's just give them one
agility so if we were doing a real game
we might have a lot more stats to
consider like move speed action points
all this stuff um so that's why these
are going to look unbalanced because
there's a lot of other things that could
be a factor that we're just not putting
in here uh let's give gnome some mental
power gnomes are smart all right so that
seems pretty good let's inert the HP on
the dwarf all right that's that's fine
the format button looks good
and you might ask why I'm using plus
equals here well
it doesn't really matter I guess and we
could just set it to equals but I just
want to make sure it's adding four
future proofing stuff basically uh
because if we're potentially changing
this in multiple places if we keep
expanding dwarf later then we want to
make sure they're accumulating and not
uh resetting
if that makes sense so if we set you
know plus one power for this Factor plus
one power for this Factor if we were
using just equals then we would just be
setting it to one every time they
wouldn't be a cumulated so that's why
I'm using the plus equals here it's just
to be a little future proof another
great thing about this pattern is well
as we if we go and change stuff about
these
the client here this main being
considered the client well this whole
file they don't need to do anything
differently so if we go and update this
piece of software and say hey we
rebalanced the race or whatever
or the classes
the client wouldn't need to do anything
whereas with the method I was showing at
the very beginning they might have to do
all kinds of special stuff because that
wouldn't involved a lot of code and a
lot of
kind of workarounds to make things work
okay let's keep going with the stats now
we want the player to have a main stats
block here so we're just going to put
that in here uh stats
stats
and we're gonna add a few other things
to the player while we're at it we're
gonna make a string of just the
character name
might as well put that in there and
we're going to add that to the
Constructor you need a race a class and
a character name
I'll make sure we set that character
name now when we go to this
implementation we're going to need a
name here
I'm gonna pull up a little DM power
program here go to my tools here name
generator there we go your car that's a
great dwarf name dwarf Warrior name
so that's all sorted out
um we just want to make sure that with
this player that we do all these stats
because you know we got some stats for
the race we get some for the class we
just want to make sure we add them to
this so first of all let's call that
function omit stats on this one
specifically notice that we didn't call
it on the others there's a reason for
that and we want to Pat simply stats
this is by reference so it's going to
modify it we can go look at this
function there it is it basically just
yeah we already went over that
sets them to something other than zero
some better defaults if you will so we
got at least some ones and some bass
stuff now let's add all this other stuff
to it
um the race and the class and we can do
that using the plus equals since we've
already got this prepared over here and
stats.h just to go along with it so kind
of got the extensions ready to go there
which is nice
so basically we can just go stats plus
equals
race stats
and then also add in the class once make
sure we actually put board class here
and then our our stats should be all up
to date we're not doing leveling in here
of course but that's something you would
want to add if you're going in for real
all right so now that this is basically
done the last thing we want to do is
just get a nice print out I'm going to
make a class here
called player underscore sheet and this
is just going to handle all the printing
um I've already made this file earlier
um basically we just want to include the
player of course
and include i o stream because we're
going to need that
and we're going to use a little bit of
IO manip to make it look a little nicer
and now I could type this all in but I
did it a few hours ago so I was gonna
paste it all over and then we'll go
through it line by line and explain what
it does all right so it's just a
function called print player sheet it
doesn't return anything it takes a const
reference to a player that's const
because it's not going to modify the
player and definitely don't want it to
so const is great and we're just doing
some console outs here
uh we're doing name grabbing the
character name race calling the get race
name out of the brace that's set same
with class except let's get the last
name I believe so what we call it
oh okay I've got some a few changes here
I'll explain it it's back in path in the
previous thing I wrote up but now it's
all just class
so it's going to show the class and I
don't know if I'm kind of doing some
specific spacing here on this section
just to make it line up nicely and now
here we have the resource name now the
resource name is dynamic it could be
Mana it could be rage it could be uh
energy so we don't know how wide it's
going to be so we're using left
alignment and setting the width to eight
because that is the width of the
greatest one of these is eight
so we're just using a little bit of
those uh there getting the spec name and
uh just putting printing out the
resources we did the same with HP we're
just doing a the current slash Max
current slash Max on the resource notice
that it's always just current resource
no matter which one you don't say get
Rage or get energy it's just always
going to be get resource the only thing
that changes is the name but you still
always just call get resource name now
this is nice because from a client and
that code's never going to change no
matter how many
things you mod in later all right then
power agility mental all right good
enough so what we can do now is go back
to our main and just call that function
well we need to make sure we include it
include
layer sheet and call it and there's
going to be a slight problem here but
I'll show you how to address that
different player sheet of player one
I think we gotta update our cmake here
make sure it's got all these files in
here okay now it should work a little
better okay but it still has a problem
here well we don't see it here but when
we go to compile it it's going to
complain that some of this stuff is
private and it can't be accessed now if
we hover over it this ID is helping it
says has declared and it's inaccessible
um it's private so what do we do do we
start making a bunch of Getters well we
could I don't really want to do that
though
or there's another option that's C plus
plus offers we can just make that
specific print function a friend so we
can go friend
and then we just put the function
signature here void
print layer sheet
I'm going to take a cons reference to
this class and that's it
now this should be happy about that it
should be okay
with the player sheet accessing these
private members since it's a friend
a current HP did I name it something
different oh I did not add that in so
yes there should also be int current HB
here and
current resource
and they should still all start at zero
I could put it we could put in the
Constructor but we could also just put
it right here and it'll essentially be
the same as putting it in the
Constructor that's a good idea to make
sure things are initialized okay there
we go got all that initialized now in
theory we could put this current HP and
resource into the stat block but the
thing is it doesn't really work too well
with the way we're doing it because
um each race doesn't want a current HP
and each stat doesn't want to current HP
and stuff like that they just maybe want
to add to the max so that's why we only
have the Maxes in here just a design
Choice there so it's specifically with
the player but now that should make our
player sheet a little bit happier I
think could we call this something else
get resource name oh it's and then
there's no spec there we go okay
so we should be able to run this and we
should get a printout of player one
let's go ahead and have a go
and there it is there's gercar the dwarf
Warrior 103 HP Max 0 out of 100 rage
three power one agility one mental all
right super cool so can we do that with
the rest sure can all right let's give
it a try player two
let's make this an elf Wizard and we
need another name let me pull up my
program get another random name here
Kimberly
cool name call this print
pipe it in there change that to a two
now we should see cambly in there as
well there's cambly different stats as
expected and we could keep going on and
on I might as well do a nomadic right
player three no actually let's make
Kimberly a rope and The Gnome wizard
something else let's find another name
here belligerent that sounds like a help
name okay that's gonna be the help name
Kimberly is going to be the The Gnome
whatever doesn't matter we'll just go
with it make sure we print player three
and we should see the gnome Wizard and
we're gonna see that the elf is now
broken
there we go they are all in there all
with different stats as expected look at
that agility oh very nice okay so now
what's super cool about this is uh well
a couple couple things you might notice
like if we make another player player
four for example we reuse gnome and we
re use Warrior let's get another random
name when s
okay so that's a weird name it'll work
just fine
and it'll get all the right stuff
and notice that we don't have to
re-instantiate gnome just still just one
gnome in memory or one gnome stats so
with this kind of method
you can you can design a system where
you can make great use of uh or what do
they call that pattern the flyweight
that's what I was trying to think of
make great use of a flywheat which was
essentially where you only implement or
uh put something in memory once and just
keep reusing so it's a great way to make
use of the flyweight wire at it too okay
so super cool okay so now you I told you
we would expand it later and show you
how easy it is whereas remember at the
beginning of the video to expand it we
would have had to you know in theory
change a bunch of switch statements
modify a bunch of things it would have
got really messy it would have been just
a huge overhead to make one little
change like let's say we want to add the
Monk class all right we want to be able
to go okay well what about monk it'd be
so cool to have a monk in the game uh
how much work do we have to do to put in
a monk and this is where the beauty of
this pattern really comes in you just go
over to race or Not Race class just go
over to class
put a monk in here put in whatever you
want he uses key sure
he gets uh one agility one mental and
maybe we'll just you know gotta make the
Monk class a little broken let's let's
give his max HP also a little buff there
we go that simple we now have a monk and
the client can just instantly use it
that's so much less overhead oh let's
make a uh
Dwarf Monk player five let's get a new
name skerak
sweet all right hit play bam monk at it
there's the Monk
so it's that simple
to make uh modifications we could do the
same for races we wanted to just add
another race we could just pop it in
there and just there we go so as you can
see there's a reason why this is a
design pattern it's very very
maintainable and it's very nice so
that's it for this video hope you
enjoyed don't forget to hit the buttons
consider supporting the channel if you
want to keep seeing stuff like this it
would mean a ton to me and uh yeah and
the community all right see you guys
next time
[Music]